has been tending to her son since last
Friday
says he's in a coma after police
allegedly beat him during
anti-government protests
I'm hurting I have no money to cater for
my son's needs in hospital I don't know
if he will speak or he will die
a few beds away 17 year old Fidel Castro
or Chiang tells us man who appeared to
look like police came to his
neighborhood and started beating and
shooting at them
he was shot eight times his friend was
killed and they started surrender
surrender
when I Surrender like this they hit me
here
They Carried some hoods
when I Surrender
the other one beat me with the boots was
having a heavy boots these black boots
these are not isolated cases most of the
injured at this Hospital have gunshot
wounds
health workers say the victims were
mostly shot in the chest and abdomen two
patients are still in intensive care
from the happenings and whatever the
injuries where the injuries are it means
that someone was targeting somewhere so
vital and this one could lead to massive
death
protests against the cost of living a
newly imposed taxes started nearly two
months ago
the government says some protesters
attacked security personnel looted and
vandalized property
opposition leader rylo dinga blames
Security Forces
Amnesty International says that more
than 30 people have been killed since
March most of them from informal
settlements this is one of the areas
where police are say to have attacked
residents at their homes the police say
they were chasing looters but residents
are well spoken to say those attacks
were brutal
and his mother can breathe again he's
out of danger
Doris oringa is still waiting for her
son onyango to wake up Catherine soy Al
Jazeera kisumu county western Kenya
and Catherine's with us live now she's
joining us from kisumu so these are
described as vigils rather than protests
what's happening
foreign yes we are standing right
outside the main hospital here in kisumu
County people have been Gathering here
for these vigils that have been caused
not just by the opposition but the
county uh the county officials who are
here so what they're doing now they have
been talking
um to people who are still injured they
are in hospital we have visited some of
this uh injured people
who many of them suffered gunshot wounds
we have uh speak we have also spoken to
families of the disease deceased as well
um we spoke to one uh family that is
preparing to bury their relatives so
what they're doing now is that they're
going to light candles uh they have
um white handkerchiefs and from here
they will go to some of the areas where
the most violent
clashes happened before between
protesters and uh the poorly so they
will go there and they're saying today
is just a day
um to moan A Day to Remember to remember
those who died and to remember those who
are still in hospital and raila odinga
the opposition leader wants the
international criminal court to take
some action
foreign
yes and rylo dinga himself uh held a
press conference on Tuesday where he
talked about those issues and he said
that other press conference he said that
the police have been using uh excessive
force and he says that it appears uh
that some communities uh particularly in
opposition uh areas some communities uh
have been ethnically profiled as well so
he says that needs to be investigated
and he wants an independent
investigation to happen as well but then
we've also had uh from the government
itself we've heard from the interior
Ministry where
um you know government officials are
saying that some of the protesters
attacked uh police there was a looting a
lot of looting going on during those
protests we also know that it's a new
people the property was vandalized uh
there was a lot of damage of property in
different areas as well so the police
are saying that they're investigating
investigating that and they're also
saying
um that what happened in those portals
amount to uh economic uh sabotage
Catherine thank you very much Catherine
sorry talking to us from kisumu